tonight Wayne is ready to step back into
the spotlight the Grammy winner is the
subject of a new exhibit at the Country
Music Hall of Fame and Museum in
Nashville where fans will find many
iconic artifacts on display from her
career as one of the best-selling
artists of all time you know you forget
where he's been where you've traveled I
mean I don't forget but seeing it all
right there in front of you is like whoa
yes it's fun actually it was satisfying
I guess you know walking through and
being reunited with all these really
great memories tonight to release her
new album now on September 29th then
although she wrote the extremely
personal record on her own she still
wants to collaborate with some music's
biggest name well I did deliberately
write to something by myself I'm very
shy about what I'm creating I need to
create by myself I need to be alone
uninhibited let everything flow you know
say whatever I want how I want to say I
don't want to be judged but a songwriter
like Chris Stapleton I would line up
around the block to write with
I'd like to write with Zia I'd love to
write with like Kelsea Ballerini I'd
like to sit down with her and just jam
out ideas so I do love collaborating yes
Elton was just particularly in exercise
and independence